we're here at hillary clinton's
headquarters now going to talk to sue of
her senior advisors about the campaign
and about this headquarters and the
culture thereof joining us now amanda
rendrea is the national political
director marlon marshall is the director
of states we're gonna have to figure out
what that means in the course of this
interview that seems like it seems like
an awesome title somebody worked for
napoleon
uh amanda start with you
not everybody who's watching knows
you've got a big title a political
director's huge thing just tell us a
little bit about your political
background how you ended up as hillary
clinton's political director for this
campaign um well i think it does start
where i grew up in a small town
but i ended up becoming the first latina
chief of staff in the united states
senate and really got a chance to see
her as a senator and really watch her
career and watch a woman rise within the
senate but also in the political sphere
and no doubt um i love the idea of
breaking ceilings
what what presidential campaigns have
you worked on first first this is it
this is the first one okay but marlon
newton uh with president obama before
coming over to the clinton campaign i
was i was i got a chance to work at the
white house for the president uh prior
to actually started one of the reasons i
started my mom teacher 36 years
and was very involved in the political
process in terms of letting us know as
kids how we got to make sure that we are
participating in that process to make
sure that we are always fighting for
education so
i started right after college got
involved in campaigns got a chance to
work for the secretary 08 during her
first run and then the president on the
general election and the re-elect and
then like you said i got a chance to
work in the white house all right so
what is director of states
well we have obviously i have a support
role we have four fantastic state
directors in iowa new hampshire nevada
and south carolina my job is to make
sure they get what they need to run very
distinct state programs that we're
building a
volunteer infrastructure in iowa that's
going to help us win iowa caucus that
we're building infrastructure new
hampshire is going to reach out to
voters and make sure we're successful in
the amsterdam primary they're great my
job is helping make sure they get what
they need so one of the reasons we're
excited to be here today is this
headquarters has not been up and running
very long it hadn't been open to the
press very much but we were allowed to
walk around talk to your some of your
colleagues all day um everybody seems to
be in a pretty good mood and seems even
though it's a young campaign and there
are a lot of people here just working
together first time
the spirit seems pretty good i'm just
wondering you all done politics before
how would you characterize kind of the
ethos of this particular campaign
i think you can feel it as you go around
it's interesting it's creative it's we
really are trying to push the envelope
of give us your ideas and let's try it
out
i think what you see is really a
creative energy um but also we're
working for a candidate who has worked
for a long time on fighting for issues
that a lot of folks here have cared
about and um you can feel that you can
feel that in the fight every day when
people are waking up saying how do i
help yeah what do we do differently how
do we make it work
and really across the different
organizations we all work together not
just in silos but across the various
organizations and that's fun and we're
very deliberate about culture probably
seeing as you walked around there's a
document that lists out some of the
culture and principles that this
campaign lives by and that comes from
her being very deliberate making sure we
have a good time that we're working for
the right reasons uh and that we all are
working together and so we're very
deliberate about that and you can feel
as you walk around there's a crazy
emphasis on health food here
i see lots of signs with fresh fruit and
vegetables who's had pizza
it's because we have pizza so much that
seeing some of the healthy stuff makes
you feel at least like you're learning
something even if you're not eating it
if you walk over by our section you'll
see grapes bananas if you walk in my
office you don't see that so why don't
we might have had cupcakes today
like 12 different ones right the
smallest i was going to say i ducked in
the gym by mary's office for the
jalapeno chips
that's right good though
there's a ton of people here i mean
you've never done a presidential you've
been involved in lots of possibilities
there's a ton of people here working on
their first campaign yeah i'm just
wondering from each of you marla stark
what's what's that what's the thing you
tell people about how to do this for the
people who've never done it before well
one i think even when you start the
interview process you just be realistic
about what you're going to get into and
make sure you're doing it for the right
reasons you're ready to work uh several
hours a day and so really kind of again
you gotta dig into why someone want to
work here what are the values they have
do those values match the values of the
campaign frankly the candidate
everyone here you feel that way
so just making sure again they're doing
it for right reasons they always remind
themselves their own personal story
because that's what's gonna only thing
that's gonna keep you going every day i
always i literally call my mom or text
her every other day be like this went
well they're like oh tough day mom but
and she's gonna want to kind of keep me
going um and so you gotta remind folks
why they're here every day you're not
gonna impress a lot of moms by saying
you text her every day every other day
every other year
yeah as a mom
right what just tells you she texts me
when one sort of political rule you tell
the younger people here um so two things
actually i say don't forget the wire
here
and remember on this roller coaster
it really is on the one hand we're doing
something really big for our country on
the other hand don't forget to enjoy the
moment every single day
because after the campaign is over i
think a lot of people goes by so fast in
a lot of ways
that there are these moments on a
campaign that
really do change people's life where
they remember them forever
and we try our best to do both of that
remember the gravity of what we're doing
really the seriousness of what we're
doing and at the same time
look around and breathe in and enjoy it
yeah campaigns are really about their
family you spend a lot of time each
other i met my wife for the campaign
2004 john kerry uh so be in the moment
and and know that's a very it's very
powerful
you know talking about family and
texting here mom and parents you know
i'm curious
but i'm curious to know a little bit
more about your father and his role in
terms of helping you
in the way that you think about some of
the issues from the campaign for some of
our watchers who might not know your
father did immigrate from mexico in the
1960s before you were born you were born
in california but um and i'm wondering
uh immigration has will be a big issue
in the campaign and already has become
such a hot-button issue uh and not just
immigration but mexico because of some
of donald trump's recent comments um
how has your father's background
affected how you think about this and is
that something that that he has talked
about what impact do you think
some of trump's remarks have had so far
um i would just say the impact on my
life in general when you come from
parents my dad was from sakatecas mexico
and my mom was from california but they
all they both work in the fields and
when you realize that somebody works so
hard for you to have the opportunities
in life
it truly is at your core and in
everything you do and being able to be
as blessed as i've been to be able to
have the opportunities i've had
it's never lost on me that there's some
kid
whether it's like my dad just wanting to
make a better life for somebody else or
growing up figuring out how do i make my
parents proud for all the hard work they
did and so when you hear something like
what trump says it really gets to at
least someone like me at the core of
what i believe this country is great for
and why i'm even working on this
campaign
and what i've said about it is it used
to be an honor i used to say it's an
honor to be a national political
director
because we're trying to build the
biggest tent that's ever been built and
being welcoming to everyone
but it's really become much more of a
responsibility to me
that i really do want everyone to feel
like
the like our campaign the democratic
party we're here we welcome you and we
give you honor and want you to succeed
in life what's your dad's analysis on uh
on donald trump
well my dad my dad well you know he
taught us all girls how to punch and so
you can imagine what he thought if i
came across a makeup be ready you know
be ready to fight um but you know
you know i think i think it's a little
bit hurtful i think he probably views it
from the eyes of my boys i have now boys
who are growing up right and what do
they think about being mexican and i
think he's a little softer in his older
age he tells me to still punch but he
tells them like it's okay it's going to
be okay we're going to build a better
world for you
um so it's been it's been interesting to
see sort of the reaction um and i think
even more so i think they understand
what i'm doing and why it's important
that we build the biggest tent we
possibly can in this election last
question for you your states
rise of bernie sanders senator sanders
doing pretty well yeah can he not willie
but can he beat hillary clinton in
either iowa new hampshire or both
first of all we always expected the
competitive primary i've heard that line
i'm representing
there's a true lie it's a true line
i think we have the staff out there that
are building a fantastic organization
they're going to continue to build that
organization and i think you'll see us
be successful in the iowa caucus and new
hampshire prime minister you don't want
to say where you can win
i think we're going to be successful and
win this uh primary campaign looking
forward to it all right
as you go around the country and spend
time in presidential campaign stats
you'll see regardless democrats
republicans people like this who
care about their candidate care about
their country working really hard thank
you both for joining us thank you
appreciate amanda andrea and marlon
marshall